coming up next week financial regulation
expose climate in a fundamental right
welcome to the agenda Lieber the rigging
of the interbank lending rate was the
scam of all scams that exposed the
rotten heart the financial world could
new rules help prevent market abuse in
Europe the economic and Monetary Affairs
Committee will vote on a new regime did
better control benchmarks used to
determine the value of things like loads
or mortgages find out how all that goes
down on Tuesday sending an email or a
text message even the most burn I'll
things we do Lisa carbon footprint as
the UN conference in Paris tours over
near our world leaders any closer to
signing off on a climate change
agreement a deal in the French capital
can very well be on the cards or what
are the challenges beyond on Monday the
Parliament will play host through
inter-parliamentary conference with
representatives from national
governments and the European Commission
the fundamental rights of e citizen are
laid out in a charter but if cross
member states are those rights be it
social religious or sexual really
respected on Monday a public hearing on
the state of play of fundamental rights
in Europe and on Wednesday inequality
will be the focus of a debate in the
employment committee we will also look
at child poverty and don't forget to
look out for your party the interview
with the director of the center for tax
policy administration at the oecd the
Organization for Economic Cooperation
and Development you'll be at the
Parliament on a Tuesday and run with his
sector general and also look out for the
sector General of NATO that we making
his maiden visit to Parliament on Monday
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week